hello hello and welcome to this video
playing EMG ugh you later see you later
nope no name but we got an Enzo yeah
let's see them yeah the night g2 line
and it's incredibly popular I never
really understood why think people yeah
really don't get much in other lines in
either cell and then they go for that
okay so you just those form that a QP
position oh okay doesn't look like a
very aggressive iqp position hmm do I go
b6 here or not now looks looks like the
normal approach maybe d5 but okay it
should be seven looks good anyway so at
least d5 here is never possible due to
95 just looks eh maybe okay but should
be one that's what he wants to do I
wonder if I should go to 60m Bishop g7 I
think I'll go for that d5 still doesn't
look very dangerous and night before
though that's a bit of a problem okay
so I have to do this directly as long as
you cannot play Bishop H form
generally looks looks quite comfortable
for black at leasts my initial
impression here now g4 also was an idea
that I didn't read it and maybe maybe I
could have done that it definitely
becomes an option wow wow that that move
just doesn't work at all okay the pin so
can I immediately use that on what to do
maybe I just take h5 I mean it's one
possibility I can also wait why g2g to
wait wait wait what about this the
street to business I can write if five
in this position takes Queen edge to
check Quincy to check tool yeah not
calculating this until the end if that's
not winning something is wrong with this
game check I mean with the game of chess
engine well there must be a win-now here
somewhere so quick Alex and hear how to
how to do that just some look the eight
or check there look the aid not seeing a
made yet to just probably pretty bad
I can also just take a pin when you
fight with the night
hmm I don't see a maid and I don't see a
clear winner after look yet even though
it looks kinda looks very bad okay let's
play move him
don't really see okay comes to them can
check here and probably just rip the aid
to control the default and play Bishop
f3 mate I don't know it feel it felt
like there should have been something
even more decisive but I'm notoriously
bad at seeing just things
and so where's the wind bishop f3
somewhere check
still doesn't feel completely completely
over check here Queen goes back I don't
see her when I don't believe this but I
don't find a win here okay Josh it here
I can check again on f4 of it I still
don't see the win check
you can take that oops what am i doing
Arnie what I was seeing here I didn't
see that he can take that stuff wow what
the heck what I simply I simply didn't
see that this was hanging this is this
awful oh my god wow I just blended that
in one move and ok the position was
utterly winning before I mean oh my god
how to hurt her that's how to hard to
swallow how idiotic can you beam oh my
god and can't he played H for which is
this is the worst move in the position
that doesn't blunder piece amazing and
it's probably worse than blundering a
piece
unbelievable crap really wonder
sometimes what I'm doing there in those
games yeah i can plug in resign or
actually what Jim that doesn't feel
right after the position that I then I
had earlier check now that he could have
done done much earlier ah what did I
tell them there's eyes I was just
terrible I mean not winning after h4 is
just like the worst h4 is the worst
possible move that doesn't blunder stuff
I mean I played that she forced my
threat and he plays h4 then okay and I
don't manage to win here this is amazing
okay I can take on the form which wins
immediately under there are probably
tons of ways to just I mean this this
win what I what I can't really what I
really what I found very good as I
didn't see anything here I mean I have
to wear maybe this is just enough I had
to [ __ ] on those I didn't see that yes
it is minus a million yeah but this is
also minus alien so channel is this this
this is no night three is winning change
this and what now night h4
threatening Queen f3 minus 15 a ver and
cam cam but this also should win I just
just blundered this in one move I simply
cannot tell you what i thought was I
thought that I just I just didn't see
that you can take it so I mean what is
the computer recommend i actually just
good to go back in yeah i simply i
simply didn't see that he can take it ya
know it's also immediately lost him
there's nothing in between that just the
total window I totally lost um okay it
was a pretty normal kind of kind of game
Bishop g5 h6 yeah he probably has to
take and here black is quite comfortable
but it's nothing special if he plays a
normal move age for as a suicide as he
cannot protect us anymore the thing is
this is my thread I threatened this
anyway he should play f3 or h3 or
something and this is just like yeah
please and please check made me
unbelievable yeah okay night FY is a
move that deserves to do sigh just
blunder peas in one move okay thanks for
watching